[Musique]
ce lundi 21 novembre le département de
La Réunion et l'Agence française de
développement signer une convention qui
vient consolider leur collaboration afin
d'accompagner les transitions
écologiques sociales et démographiques
du territoire
les grands axes sont ceux des priorités
du
Conseil Général de la Réunion président
en même temps a appelé tout à l'heure et
qui sont ça fait au centre des priorités
stratégiques de la mdr la transition
écologique le développement agricole
l'inclusion sociale tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour répondre à la fois au
besoin des populations aujourd'hui et
préparer les défis de demain ça se
traduit par un accompagnement des
actions de coopération internationale
auxquelles participent le département
qui sont également
des sujets qui intéressent beaucoup la
FD dans le cadre de l'Indo pacifique et
puis au-delà de ça ça peut se traduire
par de l'appui à la définition de
politique publique des études et aussi
mais c'est très important un partage de
nos de nos analyses au plan financier
l'AFD finance régulièrement le plan
plurianuel d'investissement du
département le département de La Réunion
a à peu près contracté des emprunts à
hauteur d'à peu près 300 millions
d'euros pour financer tous ces projets
d'investissement les routes les collèges
les bâtiments publics la transition
écologique et sur ces 300 millions la
moitié vient de la FD tout simplement
pourquoi parce que nous quand nous
mobilisons des enfants nous devons le
faire au meilleur condition de marché et
on va chercher les meilleures conditions
de taux pour que la collectivité
départementale ne s'endette pas trop et
donc auprès de la FD on trouve de bonnes
conditions c'est ce qui fait que la FD
représente la moitié donc des encades de
la dette départementale et je salue ce
partenariat en ce que au-delà des
financements que nous obtenons nous
obtenons aussi des soutiens en termes
d'ingénierie pour mener à bien des
projets il nous faut des ingénieurs il
faut faire des études d'opportunité de
faisabilité et autres et là il dit à nos
côtés pour cela
[Musique]